so what is your musical background then
my musical background is piano lessons
right as a group
just but but not like intense piano
lessons like like the guy down the
street mr coletti taught me piano since
five years old sort of thing i would say
from like six to maybe
12 or 13 and then maybe i went back for
a little bit when i actually was
interested in it because at that time i
was just like oh he had to go take piano
lessons
i hated practicing hated all that and
then there came a time when i started
getting more interested in music and i
was like you know i'm going to go back
to mr coletti and take some lessons with
him now i'm much older yeah went back
down there and i started asking him
the thing i wanted to know was like i
understood i could pick out a melody on
the piano and that was fine like i could
play star wars whatever yeah uh
but what i didn't understand was what
was happening underneath all of that and
that that and he goes oh you mean like
chord progressions i'm like i don't know
maybe and he goes it's like this you
start on a c you go to an f you go to
that
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy
[Music]